you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network now each week
I eyelash haver owner of dogs man who
enjoys a turkey sandwich Dave Anthony
leased a story from American history to
his friend Gareth Reynolds who has no
idea what the topic is going to be about
now what's wrong with me letting people
know who I am because these are just
cool or important so there I'm done
there's someone out there right now that
just was like I like a turkey sandwich
but that still is not it's not it
nobody's gonna be like hey you hear that
Dave Anthony likes a turkey sandwich no
that'll never be roast people about
eyelashes I would so and so what you're
I know I'm just separating myself um
though that's just saying we have
different wires I think it's a rude
movement we have different lives it's
just it's probably just not meant for
the intro of this show in particular you
could just do another show that's all
about you
and you could just list off all these
useless things and I do mean useless
things that you've mentioned about
yourself over the past couple years
since you've started this bit that is
just unless somebody wants to bring me a
turkey sandwich bring you the version of
you that lives in your head is as real
as I real world he is a king he's the
real world I think what it is you're
just mad because people don't know a lot
about you that's I'm very comfortable
with that disagree very and called it
quote is jam-packed I'm the [ __ ] guy
Dave okay Garrity but it's good and this
is not gonna come particularly quad cast
yeah
five park officials now hit him with the
puppy you both present sip arguments
[Music]
that somehow has made it through both
versions that's weird
yeah no it's weird no no we talked about
Twitter last night so if you want to see
our personal stances on my name and the
origin story they can just go on the
Twitter that's someone pretty some
interesting evidence culminating in an
album recording I will be at a good
night's comedy club June 6 or 7 so
that's a place where June so what
they're saying a goodnights is a the
comedian puts people to sleep
I mean hopefully that is my that's my
target comedy attic Bloomington Illinois
Indiana sorry I keep doing that June
20th through the 22nd comedy off
Broadway Lexington Kentucky June 27th
through the 29th it's actually way off
Broadway
laughs Boston July 19th through the 20th
in Boston shockingly Acme comedy club
Minneapolis Minnesota July 30th through
August 3rd The Improv in Denver Colorado
August 9th through the 11th and then the
Fremont Abbi Seattle Washington August
17th comedy club on state in Madison
Wisconsin on August 22nd through the
24th and that's where I'll be recording
an album and you can go to my website
Gareth Rowan's calm find information on
all that stuff some places just don't
have the ticket links up yet so that'll
be that's kind of a chronology at Cole
thing that's not helpful thank you and
then I got one guy said one more thing
real quick
yeah buddy of mine named James Kirkland
self-published a book called friend of
the devil the Bill Walton mysteries and
it is so goddamn funny and it's
basically with Bill Walton and Dave
Pasch the guy that they that he calls
games with aside from calling games also
solved mysteries and it's a hell of a
read so it's called the Bill Walton
mysteries friend of the devil
james kirkland yeah and I have a new
podcast by the way it's about the west
wing right me and writer Josh Olsen who
is oscar-nominated writer we sit here
and we discuss the west wing you do it
here every week we do it here and
basically talk about the show and how
people in our political world have
decided to adopt that sort of style of
politics as if it's reality when it's a
TV show that's crazy
and good and good because also these
stories you hear about Aaron Sorkin are
like he would just eat a bag of
mushrooms and go write an episode so
that's actually I support that I
shouldn't knock that yeah so also just
to report a lot of people asking Adri
Adri Adri Adri Adri Adri or a did say
yes to mayan
yes Maya they are going to the prom
together they're going to the prom
together
we kill the f out that's happened she
said it was very emotional for them not
we were more emotional we were you cried
a little bit I haven't been crying about
it I did not cry I remained a man a
strong man but if you did cry those
beautiful eyelashes that you keep
posting about would have surely been
able to soak up some of the wood hangs
off of it like a summer roof you are
just here's something and if you want to
watch this it's only all things coming
to YouTube Jim yeah so check out West
Wing thing is the name of my other
podcast I think that's all people keep
telling me to say stuff and I was forget
that's my deal we are brought to you by
Squarespace
a website company where you can website
copy ok look we we use a Squarespace we
use it for my personal website your
personal website we use it for your
resources we enjoy Squarespace that's
our deal we love it we hug it we make we
make love to it we do all kinds of
things it's user friendly its user look
you can turn your cool it into a new
website you can showcase your work you
blog
or publish content sell products and
services of all kinds actually don't
blog but do other stuff by getting
another website don't block well I mean
I there's certain people who I'm
interested in hearing from them for the
most partner promote your physical or
online business announce an upcoming
event or special project or more they
got great templates again I've talked
about that before that's why I enjoy
Squarespace
it's super easy it was for me powerful
ecommerce functionality that you sell
anything online everything optimized for
right out of the box you can buy domains
200 extensions it's look what am i it's
awesome yeah it's good so I get 24/7
award-winning customer support so here's
what you do you go over squarespace.com
you do a free trial right so you check
it out you find your template you like
and then when you set it up you pay for
it so you do your free trial and when
you're ready to launch use offer code
dollop to save 10% off I am this is very
emotional I really like use of code all
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
enter code dollop which is our podcast
we also we also are sponsored by quip
which is a toothbrush I just got new
brushes in the mail oh you did you know
how I know you get them cuz you gotta
know because they sent me an email that
they're sending them to you because
somehow there's some sort of there's a
lot of wires crossed on me um I think we
ordered it all through the adult so
equipment it is a great toothbrush the
best part is that you can stick it on
your mirror right yeah I mean it's
really awesome great for you can put
your toothbrush on it probably and other
companies laugh that guy out of the room
yeah get out of here you idiot it turns
out that guy's the best guy look you
were not brushing your teeth right
before you got it I'm English I didn't
know what I was doing I just was using a
twig and just jamming it into the molars
it's cut you basically supposed to brush
you supposed to brush for 2 minutes
today so what it does is it has a timer
and it tells you when to flip go up your
next quadrant that's what I call him
now the robot goody another quadrant and
it just tells you when I move it around
and then two minutes and then it turns
off its like hey you're done
so it's charged for its yeah oh he's
done done so kids there's a new brush as
same as the original version just
tweaked for size down mouths kids are
inspired to brush better and more often
with oral care and looks and feels like
the products the adults in their life
use and they're proud to use quit help
them develop a grown-up routine without
childish gimmicks kid-friendly features
like small brush head watermelon anti
cavity toothpaste and rubber grip
handles in colors little ones below and
I can attest to this he loves it
your little one than my little one
whatever the key sensitive sonic
vibrations for an effective clean that's
gentle on your sensitive gums why people
brush too hard that's you yep and some
electric toothbrushes are two braces I'm
a great brush I've always been a great
pressure as a matter of fact my wife
used to make fun of me for how long I
take which would be two minutes because
I have always been a great brushes I
recently got stitches right so you are a
different and I still have the sutures
in my mouth just for anyone who's
curious nobody it's not like a big
little string factory yuck so that's why
we love quip and why over 1 million
happy healthy mouths do to quip starts
at just $25 and if you go to get quip
calm slash dollop right now you can get
your first refill pack for free
that's your first refill pack for free
at GE t qu IP comm slash stop and refill
pack of courses they give you a battery
and they give you the new head for your
brush every three months which i get
every three months and then i just pop
it on and i am happy as a clam and my
teeth thank me claim happy as a clam for
us to know okay find an angry clam find
a happy plan an angry one
[Laughter]
a classic argument 13th century whoa
what Dad yeah that's a far way to grind
now
Crusaders returning from Europe yeah
deep yeah okay Crusaders returning from
Europe brought three important spices
with them from the Holy Land gold
frankincense myrrh cinnamon cloves and
nutmeg Wow interesting
they brought others but those are the
big three okay because there was
obviously no refrigeration the spices
were used as preservatives to combine
with fruit and meat to make protein last
longer interesting okay so one more time
cinnamon nutmeg and cloves okay the
spices were used in pies which started
in medieval Europe so middle of Europe
is pie ground zero I'll say this regular
Europe's still strong pie territory oh
yeah there's still oh yeah there's a lot
of rice with meat in it there's a lot of
pie action go on yeah pie is an English
word yeah I'm not at all surprised it
was first written in the 14th century
the assumption is that it is the same
word as magpie shortened or the same
word okay
Magpies are known to collect all kinds
of things in their nests I told you
about the eye eaters yeah yeah they're
ayat a curse they know like ice that's
what fosdick told us yeah the bucket may
be smoked a joint yeah and yeah big big
map eyes try to kill kill people in
Australia but everything tries to kill
people Australia that's just there
although you talking about straying
they're like well you guys have bears
when's the last time a bear killed
someone except for like a couple months
ago yeah grizzly man that's slowly here
a man's brain get eaten buried the bear
the Baron up in Canada killed a guy and
and his wife and it turned out the guy
was a fur of fur oh yeah so then I say I
was like oh my god some guy and his wife
got killed by Barry so sad and then
they're like oh he's there killing
animals referring like okay so like
with liam neeson the bear exists is what
happened so so Magpies build the nest
with just all the stuff they can find
for instance so this is what the pie was
right so whatever you put in a pie
you just throw okay catch all right for
instance a recipe from 1450 included
this is probably I mean this is going to
be disgusting yeah it's the worst thing
ever
here's here's a recipe 1450 beef beef
sweat sweat so it's like the fat okay
from like the kidney of an animal it's
it's a it's a fatty it's a flavoring
flat fat capons capons
are capons coupons I don't know I don't
know it's not keeper I don't know I've
never heard of a cave on him so our
coupon I'm sure it's kept on hens both
Mallard and teal ducks rabbits
Woodcock's
and large birds such as herons and
storks plus beef marrow hard-cooked egg
yolks dates raisin imprints get me a
fork bringing up the end with prunes oh
so you're just having a bird cow kidney
prune pie yeah you're putting everything
in there magpie have you never wanted to
have beef with stork heron and Woodcock
well I would love to try a teal duck
there was so much meat because for
centuries pie was a way of preserving
food I don't know so because it is
because it's made into a pie at last
longer we'll get to it okay it was a
cool climate food that was baked in a
serious thick crust a thick wall of
dough a couple of inches high Jesus so
it's like they're not this is not crust
this is protective layer that's right
right 14th century chef ro quote help we
don't know what we're doing
send hell we all up diarrhea and then
we're putting it in pies quote have
great pie shells and to make them higher
crenelated a can support meat cred
elated meant to decorate it with square
notches like on the top of a castle wall
I mean what am I supposed to picture
right
a castle pie it's a big pie I mean it's
a big enough pie that it can it can have
a place for centuries and guards put the
King inside the pie the old word for pie
crust the original word for pie crust
was coffin C Offy n which meant that's
really appealing yeah yeah what's in the
coffin slice a coffin it's full this is
kidney in it too
sorry keep banging the table people got
mad last a couple weeks ago and called
me where they get it they noticed yeah
no they were agreement at me on youtube
I he I didn't look they just told me
also I don't care about you okay
it was almost like medieval caning
except inside was almost always meat and
outside a crust so it's a version of
caning it's what they're doing but it's
a pie this edible cans
well I can't usually you weren't
supposed to eat the crust
look III genuinely walk around all the
time thinking of how spoiled we are yeah
yeah but this is oh yeah so they're
making crusted pie they're making pie
and they're like don't eat the crust
just need that's right melange of things
we've just eat the garbage inside yeah
we picked up every animal we could find
on the road and we don't eat the crust
just eat the trash bag in the middle so
Stanny pies really it opens up when you
get inside it was a two-bedroom there's
a gorgeous
Sani pies were where there was no baking
dish or pan use the crust obviously had
to be very thick to hold the pie it's
not like just thinking of like a
deflated football with meat inside of it
and crust now it's so the crushes
there's definitely inedible for the
standing pie standing pies were huge and
could be eaten for up to three months so
now we're talking a giant just a giant
huge box rust yeah like a like I mean
it's seriously like a home and you're
again you're just digging into the baby
everybody not eat the crust you'll die
every every night you're digging in and
pulling on something Aaron oh my god
it's a chipmunk like you just pulling
out whatever awesome flavors you know
yeah how big I mean how big is it's huge
because it has to go because if they're
eating and up for three months every day
probably every meal it's a bus how big
is this [ __ ] yeah yeah it's a big
[ __ ] pie man the largest pie recorded
the things that I've never heard the
largest recorded pie in the Middle Ages
was nine feet in diameter and weighed
around a hundred and sixty-five pounds
[ __ ] Wow so you just get to dig into
that baby for months oh so great right
no how is the pie today the same as it
was imagine it like month eight when
you're like man we're almost through it
we can almost make a new one but I don't
know here's what I understand yeah why
couldn't you just are they just over
buying ingredients why couldn't well I
think if they go out and hunting or
whatever and they have a bunch of kills
what are they gonna do with it you need
to turn into like a jerky situation or
this is better because this is like you
know more flavorful and meaty and yeah I
don't think there's anything great for
me I've never had anything better than
like a two and a half months old
cooked Blackbird honey we're going to
the Anthony's hurry up they got a pie
that's only four months old so he says
there's a heron in it the big big
putting fish chicken yeah whatever and
beef the whole thing it all goes in it's
like you're eating Noah's Ark it's all
tasty it's all yummy that's the term one
thing
so this nine foot in diameter pie
contained two bushels of flour 20 pounds
of butter for geese two rabbits for
ducks geese is big yeah four Woodcock's
what's it Woodcock is it like a little
uh well the teachers at a bird is it a
bird huh
is it a bird I don't want to get dirty
here I'm not trying to do either
I haven't said I think it would cost
probably a bird eye but it sounds more
like a little woodchuck fella I bet it
it's a bird
okay yeah six Snipes four partridges
we're not even gonna talk about what the
hell is snipe is Snipes kind of bird
it's a night bird night but two cat
tongues - curly even the cow tongues you
like we don't want to taste this six
pigeons and seven black bronze
I hope they took the feathers off let's
just hope that so they would cut a hole
in the crust take out what they wanted
to eat migrate scooping into bowls then
plug the hole back up with what when a
standing pike came out of the oven
they'd pour melted butter through a hole
in the crust to hermetically seal it
since they were going to be eating the
pie for weeks they'd throw tons of
ingredients in there for more flavoring
this highly seasoned combo of meat sweat
dried fruit became known as the mince
pie man spies got the look on your face
my grandmother every Christmas would
make 800 of them yeah and it would all
be everyone's job to just be like god I
love him yeah
and you just Oh y-yeah but I'm sure
those mince pies that I had in
comparison to this is a whole different
situation yeah and you're also trying to
survive
yes important to have nutrients for sure
because the spices in a mince pie had
come from the Holy Land they had a
religious connotation after a while the
Catholic Church started teaching that
the three spices signified the gifts of
the three wise men to the baby Jesus
well I was a little ahead of that one
yeah I mean yeah okay
so hi Jesus that's when mid-space nice
yeah well okay
that's when mince-pies became part of a
Christmas tradition okay for Christmas a
mince pie was made in an oblong have you
ever had a mince pie no yeah and I never
will
that's the cool thing yeah thank you for
Christmas a mince pie I'm not a huge pie
person I love pumpkin pie look I would
[ __ ] I would I personally I would [ __ ] a
pumpkin pie if I could like I love I
know it's legal in England there it is a
lot of pie yeah shepherd cottage mint oh
I know and it's the same they do it in
Australia they have a little bit yeah
but yeah I don't I don't get it I've
never went every time I've been
Australia I've looked at the pie be like
no I don't want that yeah
and they put everything and there's all
kinds of meats in McDonald's hi face
when I was a kid I used to eat chicken
pot pies I was kind of a thing
yes--that's Piyush meat but last time I
heard a chicken potpie I was soundly do
know that it has a religious context
because it seems so weird that it's
pious how do you feel about yourself
right I don't feel good and I thought I
would for Christmas a mince pie was made
into an oblong shape to represent Christ
crib in the manger I mean and the top
crust often had a pastry figure of the
baby Jesus on top sure right you put in
homage and I'm sure it look exactly like
it oh yeah it doesn't look right to see
he looks a bit smashed but because we've
been digging kidney out to be
performance it was common for the mince
pie to have 13 ingredients to represent
Christ and His apostles normal totally
normal just normal stuff of course this
meant Puritans hated the mince pie
English Puritans believed mince pies
were superstitious adulterous
abominations and Pope eschew fish
Papa Papa Papa Papa sure Papa sure I
know why Popish
whatever they think it's a you know Pope
related
Willie any kind it doesn't have 13
ingredients in it we're not crazy the
mince pie it was a purely Roman Catholic
creation and therefore evil they saw
Christmas as a pagan holiday sure Oliver
Cromwell's Puritan council abolished
Christmas on December 22nd 16:57
amazing yeah that's what Fox News is
worried about that's right yeah and and
yeah it happened so they have reason to
be scared see this guy just abolished
Christmas yeah yeah Christmas is not not
legal Christmas it was for a while to
mince pie was in aid and then some guy
just came back and he was like I we're
having Christmas again it's good it's
gonna be great it's good it's nice those
things that we thought of over the years
about how we want to make it better will
now do if you stand under this you
kissing we're putting this on the
[ __ ] tree now right back what are you
doing well Christmas is not right for
cheesy yeah Oh God come on
it was a kiss he's standing under the
leaf that's our Christmas is our
Christmas Christmas miracle mince pie
obviously in a dark place now because
it's part of Christmas celebrations sure
in London soldiers patrol the streets
and would take by force if necessary
food being cooked for a Christmas
celebration by quince pies just so
Christmas raids Christmas pie raised
right some people thought that
specifically mince pie was made illegal
of them inspire was not create
celebrations were so like a festive
cooking of any nature was now just like
they just kick in the door well where's
your [ __ ] boys give us the goose we
know you celebratin sorry miss give us
the yams as well it's over we're done
well and we're leaving and no more
celebratory cooking now I'm or religious
dishes all right all right
what can I put blackbirds in me pie oh
let me have a word with him boys boo
all right you could do it but don't be
praying around it or anything fancy like
that all right question got all my we've
got a lot of places to kick the door in
and make sure they're not having
Christmas geese whoa
can I put the baby on top well that's
just a regular paint gun honestly now
she's pushing it because now she's
saying she was put baby on baby
she says you're breaking a baby but it's
slippery yeah we think it's a slippery
slope right you can put a baby baked in
no way beat a baby Jesus
what a baby Jesus all right now if you
refer to it's baby Jesus we'll be back
and we'll put our foot through your
bloody pie all right be no more
questions even should I even sit there
try to come up with one of you got going
all right all right that's all right you
see very sneaky so like a miracle baby
though cuz we had a hard time making him
give us a crust now now you try to make
a baby Jesus on the pie yes you are
he's called a miracle baby yes you did
you did it was validating at the end so
people went back to begging the mince
pies round again after the Christmas
celebrations were made illegal so they
look like you know nothing to with
Christ right so now it's a secret spy
mince pie right yeah a mince pie
so the Puritans who came to New England
brought their mince pie hatred with them
okay
some New England colonies passed laws
against Christmas okay
plymouth Governor William Bradford
called mince pie quote idolatry in a
crust Wow yeah I mean I I think we're
nuts now but obviously we have we have
to maybe give credit to humankind a
little satirist in both England and
America made fun of the Puritans hate of
mince pies it was the perfect symbol of
the Puritans fanatical rejection of
earthly pleasures sure yeah sure of
course but mince pie survived
underground living in the shadows
through the Puritan rule I just got like
dark areas underground room it's a group
I was telling you about
hey boys good Danny we've got a little
bit of a PI Club how many one night
those reputation took a major hit in the
colonies in 1734 your writer who was sad
about the treatment of mince pies this
guy's reputation for yeah so he sat
about the mince pies reputation sure he
wrote quote invade against Christmas pie
as an invention of the Scarlet [ __ ] of
Babylon the devil and all his works he's
saying the Scarlet Letter pie yeah
basically yeah the sweet pies been
ruined by the Puritans so eventually the
Puritan rule of New England colonies
waned and the mince pie came back yes
1800s and it stuck around because it was
still a good way to preserve meat and
the hell did you stumble upon I mean I
wish I could tell you but it just
happened this guy wrote a great article
about mince pie and then I just started
looking into it
I'll said I'm just for hours got just
looking at every mince pie story in the
eighteen hundreds of newspapers and
she's like like reading for hours about
mince pie in newspapers I mean that's
that's really what my life was this week
oh this is good mince pie story yeah
honey come to bed
I can't this I just went down a pie hole
really I was not a pie hole you want
have a pile so it sticks rack it's a
good way to preserve meat so
as much as you want to try to get rid of
it it's just article right right
the other the other ways are to eat
dried beef and salt pork you know right
so the gooey concentrated sugars kept
bacteria at bay by sucking the moisture
out of the meat action verbs and that
are just distraught Oh sexy the sucking
gooey gooey sucking bacteria yeah
also spices act as antibacterial agents
so the mince pie wasn't gonna go away
because parents Puritans hated it due to
it being practical mince pie mince pie
slowly spread out of New England down
the coast then into the tea into the
tears by the middle of the 19th century
mince pie it was popular everywhere
Europeans had settled in America okay
the popularity may have been due to
booze mince pie he was full of it
huh okay and Americans that we're
pie-eyed comes from maybe oh yeah it
might be my babe salutely might be and
america was settled by European
countries the top ten alcohol consuming
countries in the world today are all
European right drinking was an important
part of American culture from daewon's
Puritan called alcohol the quote good
creature of God well finally yeah some
sense finally they did one thing right
by 1770 Americans drank alcohol with
every meal booze was in mince pie every
meal every meal every single meal
interesting so your morning breakfast
cocktail was called an eye-opener yeah
okay well not everyone there are some
people that did but most people partook
okay
now let's say you're back in this time
are you partaking yeah without question
on Earth's 100% yeah
the eye-opener sometimes came in the
form of mince pie in New England in the
colonies everyone drank even toddlers
they're already drunk
isn't that amazing yeah that's great
and Americans only drank more I mean it
doesn't like I I do not think you should
do this nobody should do this but I mean
I would love to hang out with a drunk
kid oh my god [ __ ] like four year old be
like buddy you were wasted okay yeah I
mean I dropped my blocks I know I say
I'm all over the place I can't do it you
[ __ ] you Benny
all right there we go yeah so as it only
increased you Americans only drink more
and more as time goes on right as the
1800s come along everyone's drinking
this is largely due to corn being grown
the Midwest so corn starts being grown
okay out in the rest of the country
which gets turned into whiskey uh-huh so
now that I have even more access to to
boost a cow they were downing 90 bottles
of booze a year per person which
includes a millions who didn't drink so
see so 90 90 bottles of booze a year is
actually way more for the people who
actually drank because it felt right Wow
90 bottles yeah good amount yeah with
all the boozing came the abolition
movement and they were hardcore as we've
learned was when we had a countrywide
intervention Yeah right
they used to cut down apple trees and
back people's backyards abolitionists
because you could use it to make apple
cider you could also eat an apple no one
did that back then I've never I'm
probably won't do what about Johnny
apples Lee but Johnny Appleseed was
actually a guy he was popular because he
brought apples to be used for booze it
had nothing to do with apples Wow he was
there to make people liquor loved him
right so by the mid 1800s they had
abolitionist had their eye on mince pies
with his alcohol content they saw it as
a gateway pie to hitting the bottle a
gateway pie era its pipe I passed my man
so you take two bites of the pie past
you right temperance crazies shunned the
pie and Protestant clergymen also still
refused to have anything to do with a
mince pie
it's pi mince pie was so bad that
Protestants would sermonize against it I
mean if you were there and like I mean I
have no ambition to go to church at all
but if he's hollering about a pie I'm J
I'm definitely like we should just skip
this I know well you got a pie you're
just like - is there something else that
you guys and from the oven came the
sinners crust the Reverend Thomas 20a
Genson was an abolitionist and a health
nut in in 1860 he described mince pie as
quote very white and in digesting
very most and indigestible at the bottom
with untold Horrors in between has he
had a pie I well probably not cuz he's
Protestants I probably never had yeah
but this approach didn't always work
after hearing Higginson's lecture
against mince pies in Chicago a dr.
Collier decided he should try one for
the first time after he did his cupboard
was always stocked with the mince pie
this is I mean it's just it mirrors so
many other things yeah you don't want to
listen to that swearing music we should
go get a CD yeah anything he's just
really against pie and then there's
people I know Jesus Christ as pounds
amazing by mid Victorian era mince pies
were considered good luck
so it's switched right to the Puritans
now the most popular
right Protestants hate it but now most
people are totally on board with mince
pie right okay except for the temperance
movement and the Protestants right we
would probably crawl a lot of cross over
there anyone who ate a mince pie anyone
who ate a mince pie on each of the 12
days of Christmas would have happiness
for the next 12 months that was that's
the proven by no that's what it's it's
like a mince pie slogan that's what they
it's the good luck mince pie
sure thing I'm starting to think we
should get rid of Christmas again
but they had to eat eat each pie in a
different house each night dumbest thing
offered by a friend
what sort of bridge riddle is this so
you thought shopping for Christmas
present was a pain in the ass now
imagine back in the day I went for 12
days you had to give 12 different
people's houses and he meant spy there's
a lot of question like as far as like
people nobody's gonna be home because
everybody I don't mean pie at someone
else's house yeah it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show you over 12 days have to go to 12
different house and eat 12 different
pies it's the desperate to you
it's the biggest pipe Mayer that we've
ever heard here we go look who's back it
was considered extremely unlucky to
refuse a mince pie ah as the nightmare
yeah oh god yes [ __ ] want another one
Ralph oh [ __ ] yes yeah talk about pie
you want one you just want a pie no I
said die we can't say no it's bad luck
yeah so Ralph died last night oh hi I
know that happens yeah Merry Christmas
yeah no he's it's good luck though he's
gonna have a good 12 years four months
who cares as the Industrial Revolution
took over mince pies went from something
made in the home kitchen to being
cranked out in commercial bakeries
finally the best kind yeah mass-marketed
pies there had always been jokes about
what was in mince pie sure like a
popular story about how a man had cut up
his old leather pants and served them to
friends as the main ingredient in the
mince pie so everyone had their stories
many stories like the time that guy put
his pants in a pie that's right right so
just kind of cute like you know lore of
the day about how a guy cut his pants
are better two people just kind of light
little tales about normal humans who are
just throwing their pants inside of
crusts sure that's correct okay but now
that pies were being mass-produced
mince pie became the original mystery
meat okay so it's the first mystery meat
like you don't know what's in it right
Charles Dickens novel The Pickwick
Papers includes a gross out joke about a
lemon pie maker who uses stray kittens
as his pie filling this wasn't yeah
there's no way that wasn't happening
oh why kittens what do you mean so P pop
people are hungry of course people are
gonna be grabbing cats and rats and dogs
anything you can and putting in a pie
like if you live at the if you're in the
upper class of course you're gonna be
eating geese and ducks but the poor
people are putting whatever they can in
a [ __ ] pie yes okay
this wasn't this isn't exactly the
stretch because food was unregulated so
there's no regulation in food this time
so the pies were considered not now
either yeah there it really is I mean I
totally roll the bag yeah the pies were
considered such a who the [ __ ] knows
what's in their item that everyone air
quotes who had been who had known
someone right known someone who had
bitten into a piece of newspaper or
buttons but we're streetcar transfers
like someone everyone knows a friend you
know right my buddy Larry
bit into a pie and there was a button in
there like it's that kind of thing he
ate a tire
yeah there's tire in the pie Larry okay
so some people are just and now that's
just kind of like an urban legend or
that yeah it's one of those things where
it so mixed pie is such a who knows what
the [ __ ] in there that people are just
like making [ __ ] up about know my buddy
there was a tin can in one it's and so
is it just cuz it's mint so like at this
point are that they're mincing the meat
to a point yeah okay I think what the
commercial pies just fully minced meat I
really don't know what's rare okay
that's like me it's like McDonald's
right although will totally advertise
for you so there's a McDonald's
commercial in Germany a woman is in a
tree she's a protesting she's like a one
of those people goes up in a tree to
stop people from cutting on the tree
there's a guy on the ground who is
Jack or whatever he's there to cut down
the tree and they're having a standoff
sure and then it goes into the night and
then they're both sitting there and the
lights of the McDonald's arch comes up
because there's a McDonald's nearby
uh-huh and they see it and then they cut
to her accidentally dropping a
mcdonald's wrapper Wow so talk about a
180 yeah that's cool so the tree hugger
has became get over how good McDonald's
does that's right okay sure that's right
sure well I'm glad you're watching
normal stuff someone sent it to me
someone just said to me you got to see
this one so commercial by commercial pie
became the go-to example of a changed
America what was once cooked at home was
now came in a can so hot pie Yemen's pie
comes to Kim the whole idea was that it
was a can yeah but now it's now there's
no but not too sure you can't ship a pie
crust around you get to ship it in a can
right ACK and mince pie does that sound
good to you it sounds pretty yeah well
considering that a fresh one sounds
terrible our one from a can is always
better much better yeah America always
find a way let me sound it probably made
oh just like the cranberry sauce out of
the jar like the truth is there's dinner
there's my pie just [ __ ] reprehensible
mince pie became the king of pies in
America on Christmas Eve 1871 the New
York Times described a pie wagon driver
whose wagon was filled with hundreds of
mince pies so many required two horses
to drive it as it delivered the pies to
customers in the 19th century people who
loved mince pie called the quote
unquestionably the monarch of pies why
does it have to be royal
the great American viand I don't know
what that is vayan an American
institution and as American as the Red
Indians what does American as mince pie
it's American as racism Yeah right also
more and more booze is being added to
mince pies well that explains some of
the popularity it really does according
to The Times mince pie was now a quote
sacred and cherished American
institution even though everyone agreed
even people who loved it
that it caused indigestion nightmares
and if you ate too much
sorted thinking hallucinations and even
death I mean the pie side-effects read
like a pill commercial what you're gonna
have high nightmares indigestion
nightmares disordered thinking
hallucinations and even death I mean
like two of those I want but yeah okay
so so they're strongly associated with
nightmares like mince pie nightmares
just like really yeah
from the Topeka citizen in 1886 headline
may be met it that is insane
yeah okay headline mince pie
unquestionably the most reliable
nightmare Hatcher ever invented what is
happening quote one plain innocent
looking mince pie will furnish enough
nightmares to go around three or four
times
well I that even me it's like the
weights and measures don't even matter I
think he's saying that it just one pie
he'll eat and long enough to get three
or four nightmares you know over three
or four days right I once slept with a
personal friend who had recently filled
himself with mince pie that's a really
weird way to say that a guy ate a mince
pie
he turned himself into a human fired
self he was a large able athlete I woke
suddenly to find him sitting on my bosom
with both hands grasping my Sonny locks
before consenting to share by couch with
a friend I now ask have you eaten mince
pie since last week if he says yes I do
not trust him I have all the excitement
I need with my own personal mince pie
nightmares that is that is the craziest
thing that's ever been in the paper I
mean what did he just say his friend ate
a mince pie and he woke up and the guy
was on his bosom playing with his
beautiful hair yeah and then now he
always does a pie check with his pals
that's right well I want you to sleep on
the couch with me obviously but what was
I study out of mince pie
came in last week if you within the week
you mean he's going back a week on the
pie not even that day Brian doesn't have
a lot of friends during the Victorian
era people got super into health fat's
people took all kinds of digestive cure
so bike wax which fit in nicely with the
eating of the mince pies and diet fads
were
big with as everyone sought to calm
their stomachs one was Fletcher ISM
named after the diet guru Horace
Fletcher okay if said you should chew
each bite at least 32 times okay
well that's quite a lot of chewing this
would lead to [ __ ] out quote a
digestion ash in little balls ranging in
size from a pea to a so-called queen
olive okay Dave look I don't want to
nobody wants to relive what you just
said I don't want to relive it but what
the hell did you just say this guy is
saying if you chew your food 32 times
when you [ __ ] it's gonna be like ashing
a cigarette it's gonna turn it digests
abash digestive act which is you know
turns into small little balls when it
comes out of it you think you have
rabbit decisive of its so-called Queen
Oliver Queen Oliver you're [ __ ] out
little pellets well and he's like this
is the way to go it's the way to go it's
the most healthy thing to do
sure is to have an [ __ ] that's
correct okay
it would also quote have only the odor
of hot clay or a hot biscuit okay
so just just not that again nobody wants
to relive it
but this man is suggesting that if you
chew your food 32 times you'll poop like
a rabbit and it's gonna smell like
biscuits that's right okay okay ready to
move on just wanted to make sure this is
very popular diet in Korea for years
great and people were pellet pooping
yeah well apparently okay but mints was
known for being notoriously indigestible
Harper's published an attack on mince
pies quote we are fond of pies and tarts
we cry for pie when we are infants pie
and countless varieties waits upon us
through life pie kills us finally what
sort of weird dark poem is that you know
read it one more time I'm sorry yes we
are fond of pies and tarts we crazy
start we cry for pie when we are infants
ha ha pie and countless varieties waits
upon us through this life pie kills us
finally okay thank you sis finally it's
a great last line by kill despondent all
right in 1888 seaman George Humphries
died of yellow fever while out at sea
but after the ship returned
report a doctor investigated turns out
on the ship it celebrated Thanksgiving
no no cook made a dozen mince pies three
mince pies were not beaten eaten and
stored away in the ship's locker quote
George Humphries of Bridgeton who was on
watch became hungry he ate a pie then he
devoured a second pie and then sent a
third pie homeward that means his tummy
I think ok but they afters binge George
became ill he died soon after and was
buried at sea quote loaded up with pie
as he had been no stones were needed to
sink his body the crust was heavy enough
for that they say the same thing
happened to bin Laden that's right yeah
that's how he yeah they got him it was
reported the doctor said quote you do
not need to use an anchor
I understand but merely a tin of pie
merely tie a pie to the chain so this is
the doctor of the ocean well the doctor
it's a anchor doctor anchor doctor and
he understands anchors sure as well as
yeah it's because obviously if you do
throw a pie as an anchor that's right it
works right I was just gonna finish it
with by saying it works yep
the Philadelphia Inquirer reported there
was nothing wrong with the pies quote
not rotten or poisoned or contaminated
mince pies mind you just mince pies what
does that mean that's what it killed him
okay
they're saying there's nothing wrong
with them they're just ordinary mince
pies okay but that's what now we're
about to have pie fever
well no you got a this is the chance you
take when you eat mince pies right ya
know it's a definitely risky pie but for
every scary tale of mince pie deaths
newspapers published poems essays and
editorials about how awesome mince pies
were the state newspaper of South
Carolina wrote how great mince pie was
in creating a better America because in
the early days quote it thinned out the
weak ones that argument is probably not
good we're people that in touch with
reality that they were just like why
can't we be like that now ya know just
in there
as the the Cato Institute of mince-pies
in 1888 Lumberjacks in a logging camp
were described as eating mince pie three
times a day that's a lot of nightmares
in 1899 the Des Moines Register wrote
about Charles King and cling a New
Englander who intended to control
eyeball pie product in New England quote
he claims his pies are sanitary and that
henceforth deception and mince pie
dreams will be unknown in England
dyspepsia dyspepsia is an indigestion
okay so he's trying to get rid of some
he's saying his pies are sanitary and it
gets rid of heartburn and the pike here
it's a clean clean mince right okay
finally right finally someone created
clean finally right clink said he knew
more about mince pie than any other man
because he was brought up in putting in
quote a pie atmosphere oh yeah does
anyone need to see any paperwork cuz I
think we all trust him clearly he's
being honest he was brought up in pie
atmosphere there's a boy he drove a
wagon my father was a pie he raised me
to be a little pie but unfortunately I
was a boy as a boy he drove a pie wagon
and always knew pie was his destiny yep
pie atmosphere checks out he has devoted
as much thought and one time mother
walked in on father having his way with
a pie sexually he put a glory hole in
the crust his wooden story was
eventually turned into a high-school
romantic comedy wouldn't all pies of the
whole of them be called the glory hole
pie man cuz its glory once you get in
there oh that's how you really freak out
the religious that's right also we're
having sex with the pies now Oh Lord my
lord oh my lord
he has devoted as much thought and time
to pi as Nikola Tesla to electricity and
and both not I mean very similar yes
yeah we've got the high guy and then
Tesla yeah both have done a lot of stuff
he called this brand of pie the sanitary
pie sure a lot of New England's were
upset by his move for pie dominance the
Chamber's Journal quote some grumblers
objected to the innovation on the ground
that
the chief attractions to the new
englander was the weird and rousing
nightmares which who which losses from
the tourism department let's so it's
like you take an ayahuasca or some [ __ ]
they want the nightmares right right so
this is their version of mushrooms right
so this guy shouldn't be doing this they
want cow pie that's right
so in rousing nightmares which supervene
on the hearty feast of a mince pie and
vary the monotony of pastoral life so
he's like I'll make pies that won't make
us lose our minds of people like you
idiot we eat the pies the trip I want to
go crazy tonight
it's an odd pie I got high if you want a
trip later but then I assume that was it
because there were no more stories after
him announcing that he was gonna be the
size man just made the proclamation and
then that was it because people were
like people like yeah people were not
into the santur that happens that there
are certain fish that people like in
certain areas like will if you eat the
fish you will trip really dill yeah trip
hard to like laughs yeah like have like
crazy ass fever dreams if you eat like
that you do eat the head and that and
you just like crazy so also they start
putting less and less meat in pies okay
after a while it was just so where are
they are is it becoming like it so this
is coming closer to what you know is a
mince pie right but it's also because
they're now able to store food better
yeah okay I think that there's so the
pie is now there's a change in how you
can store meats and it changing how you
can do things right so there's less
reason to have it in a pie right okay
but so they just still do the the sweat
which is the the fat right whatever
dried fruits like raisins seeped in
brandy or rum mm-hmm yep this sounds
very familiar to whatever the temperance
movement began to swing the pendulum
back the other way they attacked mince
pie because of its liquor content and
the courts did not help either a judge
in Pittsburgh made a court ruling
mince pies in 1907 okay the people vs.
pie a man had beaten his wife and
children causing them to flee their home
after learning the man had eaten three
pieces of mince pie shut up
judge Miller ruled mince pie him son
consumption was except accentuate in
circumstances shut this guy pled pie he
put are you kidding the judge placed
some of the blame on the wife for
serving him mince pie oh my god what
Your Honor my client here unfortunately
was out of his control he was out of his
mind
he'd had three pies that this woman fed
him you are lit yeah I mean a lot of
papers I read like mocked the judge for
this thing but it's yes illegal so yeah
that guy was like I can't believe that
worked
some people agree with the judge many
did not from the Democrat and chronicle
wrote quote the mince pie is denounced
as hypocritical seductive ingestible a
promoter of nightmares an arouser of the
liver to rebellion an invitation to
man's most vicious impulses to assert
themselves and do their worst all such
talk is slanderous insincere and
reprehensible
wait is that pro pyre Antipas pro-pot he
fell very mad right about the judgment
times pie okay
the writer goes on because he thought
mince pie was delightful quote it is a
beneficent home influence a domestic
harmonizer an agency for peace in the
family this is so insane that nobody can
just be like it's also just pie just so
we all know it's also just a pie if this
pie made me kill my wife you fool this
pie will give you a strength you'll be
stronger than any man if the Chicago
magistrate should take the trouble to
make a thorough investigation he would
probably find that the unfortunate man
whose case had been noted was
demoralized by being deprived of mince
pie probably his wife refused to make it
or didn't know how we think there was a
second pie so he literally he
grassy knoll Inc I so the judge blame
mince pie yes and now he's blaming the
wife right right so at least everybody's
wrong yeah so at least nobody here is
saying like hey this guy's a dick who
beats his family right Yeah right back I
was like I can't believe no one saying
anything serious try and turn up the
ring hi
my nephew sent me a message bad timing
your ass
so the Chicago trib a straight oh I
already did that so meanwhile the wife
is just sort of like this is fair this
I'm glad this kind of went this way yeah
I mean it's really later that year Alan
Albert Allen of Chicago was arrested for
shooting his wife in the head Oh God
what is about to happen Alan explained
quote how well you know officer I had
had a couple of pause that night not
prized you'd have been hollering at her
quote I ate three pieces of mince pie at
11 o'clock and got to dreaming that I
was shaking dice the other fellow was
cheating and I tried to shoot his finger
off when I awoke I was holding the
pistol my hand and my wife was shot okay
[Music]
so he killed his wife and he blamed it
on pie that's so the stakes are getting
higher Wow okay in 1907 the Secretary of
Treasury and chairman of the Republican
National Committee
George B kurta Lou was suddenly the
focus of presidential talk after an
article was published that his lunch is
often consisted of mince pie the press
then thought he must be running for
president what because he's he's they're
saying he's like oh look at me I'm like
you New Englanders I'm a mince pie eater
well obviously he's running for
president he had PI quote some of the
Yankee papers insinuate that the
publication of the quarterly luncheon
menu meant the launching of the
quarterly presidential boom while others
think the revelation of mr. Carter Lou's
pie-eating proclivities makes him the
ipso facto and part excellent
the New York England the New England
candidate chordal who apparently also
enjoyed clam pies for breakfast oh my
god should not be in charge of anything
clamp I assume that's just like a clam
chowder maybe but who wakes up and is
like chowder that's what I'm in the mood
for chowder oh you know it goes great
with coffee mmm hot clams
ah the article in on quote mince pie has
helped make him what he is he is not the
man to turn his back upon his friends
nor to use them as his ladders no no
this man eats pie if he goes to the
White House mince pie will be honored
there there it is mince pie was the jam
there was no other pie like a mince pie
in America it was eaten as an entree and
as dessert and in parts of New England
as breakfast it was eaten year round
though it was more popular in winter
everyone had mince pie on Thanksgiving
and Christmas [ __ ] waste on his pies
right now it's crazy
I can't drive dude I had too many men
spies earlier apparently there was a
time when one was supposed to settle
down and eat less mince pie there what's
what there what the hell did you just
say there was a time when people were
split with a man they're supposed to
settle down and his partying days are
over yes well my pie days are over I'm
looking for a lady to marry
I'm just got to settle down I've had my
fun I've had my night on the pies but
unfortunately now I'm a little bit older
I'm looking for a lady to kill when I've
had a slice or two according to the
Trenton steak is that quote this time
comes in Lion lives of some men when
they're obliged for the sake of other
members of the family afraid of
nightmares to refrain from eating mince
pie well I live quit pie let their
knowledge that there are others who
appreciate it and who can eat it with
temerity and a knife out to give some of
them joy whether it does or not what so
he's living through others right hi
Carrie asleep Jimmy tell me about the
pie you ate since I can't tell so I'll
kill my wife well I don't want to
rub your face in it it's so good there's
so much stuff in it that I'm not aware
of no man maybe it's worth it to kill my
wife I've had so many nightmares and I
generate when a Yankee physician claimed
to mince pie it was bad for America's
health the New Orleans Daily States
paper shot back quote the Republican
dynasty at Washington may overthrow the
Federal Constitution the rights of the
states and pluck the stars from the blue
field of the national and sign but the
mince pie will continue to be the
nation's comfort and pride well that's
quite a hill to die on isn't it
pretty much they pretty much said
everything about America doesn't matter
except for me and you want to tear up
the Constitution [ __ ] in 1909 a 50 pound
mince pie was given to President Taft by
God and what he was like no no he loved
mince pie but a 50 pound mince pie big
pie is the same because he gained weight
in office it could be the whole pie it
was given to him by new york-based ready
supply the whole pie nothing but the pie
pie so I was given to him by near
Baker's for Thanksgiving for his
Thanksgiving meal okay
it was deliberate in an oak case he was
also set a 26 pound possum from Georgia
whose what is a Secret Santa all right
so what are we gonna give Taft we all
know he's in charge as a big-shot we're
gonna grease the palms a little bit so
we got our 50 pound pie anything else
you want to throw in there I found a big
fat possum we should put in there that's
a great idea Harry that's a great idea
all right so we're gonna give him a 50
pound mince pie and then we'll just give
him this 26 pound possum all right I
think that's it we put a ribbon on it
get her out the door mince pie it was
the main food item Americans longed for
when they were traveling in other
countries once an immigrant came to
enjoy the taste of mince pie it was a
sign he or she was assimilating into
American life you're one of us now
I feel sick yeah that's right you're
gonna have horrible nightmares don't
keep your firearms near the bed Congress
debated making alcohol illegal at a
House Committee
hearing on a bill to make alcohol
illegal congressman amok the
prohibitionists Theodore Sutro quote if
the law can say to a man thou shalt not
take a sip of wine or beer or whiskey or
brandy it can by the same Authority say
to him thou shalt not take a mouthful of
MIT's pie I give it as my firm belief
that as many murders have been committed
by dyspeptic swear ever indigestion errs
made dyspeptic by too much mince pie as
by men inflamed by strong drink this is
not like it's so similar to all the dumb
debate like when does life begin total
when is a pie a pie when is a pie
alcohol when is it a food what comes
first the pie are the ingredients in the
pot that's a great question after the
guy made this connection the committee
hearing room burst into laughter the
representative of the women's Christian
Temperance Union said there would be no
mince pie writer attached to the bill
the women's Christian Temperance Union
had already endorsed a pie that was made
without liquor what the hell kind of
garbage pie is up thank you the
temperance bill did not pass on that
occasion so the mince pie question was
left unanswered in 1910 dr. Fenton Turk
of the Chicago of Chicago sorry not the
Chicago no no no one gave a lecture
during which he declared quote the
graceful self-controlled Turk is the
superior of the nervous lank New
Englander what does that mean he's
saying that the Turks are that knowing
those are weak and anxious basically and
the Turks are awesome people okay
the guy's name is also Fenton Turk sure
I was this was due to diet he said
specifically baked beans and mince pie
he said the mince pie which their
systems could not assimilate were slowly
reducing New Englanders to brutes
everyone laughs and then go to a patriot
game
quote mince pie and baked beans are
bringing about the deterioration of the
people of New England throws baked beans
in there plus these beans ain't helping
it mix those together
the Boston Globe responded quote the
aspirations cast by the learned doctor
on our mince pie and baked beans we can
overlook but we most respectfully resent
being rated as inferior to the Turk yeah
yeah a few years later French
psychoanalyst entre Trudeau said all
Americans were going down because of
mince pie and corned beef and cabbage
he said yeah and he said that the
natural advantages Americans have over
other white men are largely dissipated
by the neglect of the American stomach
well it's good to be able to root for
this guy obviously we have a hero yeah
we finally have a man rises if the
reason why you're no longer fully
superior to other races is pie your pie
eaters quote Americans are the worst
eaters in the world
you're atrocious corned beef and cabbage
and your horrible mince pie are but
examples of your unspeakable menu and we
end like and thank society today was
like oh just get started are you kidding
me have you ever had a hot dog pizza
yeah we're putting pizza in pizza now
when the stomach fails the race begins
to die out the true American has already
begun to disappear you are too much
addicted to your mince pie and kindred
gastronomic nightmares to give them up
they will be your downfall it is the
black man who will succeed him as ruler
this guy he's French yeah okay that's
still no excuse what true Dom was not
aware was that black Americans loved
mince pie as much as whites
so his fear of a black dominated America
adieu to mince pie was not going to
happen the nation's largest black
newspaper the Chicago Defender still
recommended eating mince pie for
breakfast yeah nice if it eats clams
well yeah
in 1912 mince pie started to take heat
for being bad for young women's
complexions there's a lot of twists in
this road Dave yeah well now now the
rights of the Temperance Union is the
temperance ladies are
doing everything they can to take down
mince pie dietitians had come out
against eating mince pies several
colleges in New England then forbid
restricted pies for female students Lulu
and Russell wrote a beauty column for
the Kansas weekly capital and she wasn't
having it with this attack on mince pies
quote the girls at Mount Holyoke are not
permitted to have mince pie at all
Wesley Wellesley Wellesley girls are
allowed mince pies three times a year
what do college girls know about the
technicalities of digestion at this at
the school girl age there is no
sensation in the functions it is the I
mean everybody's insane it is not a
tribute to higher education that they
admit they are rearing a class of girls
who cannot digest mince pie what is
going on it is amazing like it is
amazing how it just is like everything
else but now we're at the point where
it's like look if you're not careful
other races will rise up and also women
you can't have any okay are we clear
white men go Matt Holyoke had indeed
barred mince pie but they did it because
it made the girls very tired after
eating it and they couldn't concentrate
in class so then everyone else just ran
with a complexion story it's the class
of prop again right
the Reno Gazette journal then
satirically wrote that they should use
mince pies on patients for surgery
oh very drill you the story headline was
mince pies is an opiate from the hunting
and Herald Huntington Herald the January
14th 1918 headline quote mince pie and
pig's feet
guess the rest I will not guess the rest
what the hell's happening grant writes
Minh night jailer at the county prison
eight heavily a pig's feet and mince pie
single is he single yes yeah I thought
well we don't know he might not be while
he does pig feet he's a prison guard
while he dosed a nightmare came grant
began to shoot up the place and was
standing on the stone steps of the jail
and his bare feet when sheriff Omar
brown aroused
he explained that he dreamed jail
delivery was in progress obviously it
was consumed in spies did he end up
killing anyone or he just didn't say be
killing him no just shooting at the jail
he was actually shooting yeah Wow
but mince-pies so it's not his fault I'm
starting to wonder my friend Jesse
Aguilar when we were in college together
it would always say I'm not responsible
for what I do when I drink tequila and
this is the same thing well I'm not
gonna he was fight with your buddy but
horrible thing he's a teacher now hey
I'm eating three pies so who knows
what's gonna happen you guys might die
all right I love pie when the 18th
amendment was passed and alcohol became
illegal in 1919 liquor lobbyists started
to carve out a loophole that made
exemptions for cooking with alcohol
their efforts paid off when they won a
court case Chicago's old distillery
versus prohibition enforcement officials
booze in the kitchen was back okay so
liquor could be you could just bake
booze yeah so I can be used for cooking
but it was regulated you need a license
it's still most of the booze that was
supposed to end up in like mince pies
found its way to the black market well
weird interesting but mince pies also
changed it became a booze pump yeah I
was gonna say I'm sure loaded with booze
the Chicago Tribune did a study and the
average Commission hi can I get planter
box
the average content of can mince pies
was 14 point 12 percent Wow much more
than a can of beer it's a glass of wine
yeah it was more than that it's like
like a huge shot of whiskey at a hotel
trade show where the cans of mince pie
were available a man said quote I love
pie this friend responded here's how
then the two men clink their plates
together like wine glasses and ate their
pie when lawmakers passed and started
enforcing food and drug laws they found
most commercial mince pie did not have
any meat in it at all so what it was
just a rum crust it was just ROM and
dried fruits mince pie slowly began to
fade after this
no one knows exactly what the cause was
there's different theories the bad
commercial version slowly killed off the
homemade pie improved in mass
availability of refrigeration okay but
no one really knows but what we do know
is when world war ii came along the
apple pie supplanted the mystified to
the mince pie and it became the American
Pie and the mince pie just vanished
that is an American thing it's still in
England yes still have it for holidays
yes but mince pie I mean maybe maybe
still New England I know what mince pie
in America is not something we do for we
differ any holiday that I like I mean I
wouldn't surprised if people knew what
mince pie is yeah I had no idea yes I
reading this yeah in England it's a
thing still totally yeah
but no it's still sold in packaging
still very holiday themed and my guess
is that the my guess is that that one
refrigeration but but the commercial can
Pike like if you're all eating a shitty
version of something you just stop
eating it
yeah that is crazy
[Music]
okay well so pie who knew I mean they
also probably like once prohibition is
over then and you have access to more
yeah options that's 100% part of it so
it became association item I really do
not like to me I've never never liked
mince pie yeah like it's not it's you
know it is it's kind of like like a jam
in the pot but it's not as good as that
it's it's weird it's weird
it just sounds gross it's just not a
good flavor in my opinion yeah
but it is still extremely popular there
well yeah it's like you grew up with it
right so yeah so like what's the stuff
that they Vegemite in in Australia which
is just the most horrendous thing I've
ever put in my mouth but they're you
know but they yeah it's all bad My
Mind's BRE no but think you grew up on
it so you're like that's the norm
thing yeah just eating clams in the
morning yeah these clams in the morning
night so if you're if you're in your
culture you're used to it then you're
like oh this is good so mince pies fine
right but I think that it's not fine and
I think these things should be abolished
what you're still calling to get rid of
the mids pie no it's fine I mean it's
great but I did not good thing when they
were just putting up the thing when they
were just putting everything in there
like that's horrifying
what's the worst thing about eating a
pie it's not a knows what it was but
you've essentially created like just a
storage unit and it's edible it's an
edible storage unit yeah which now that
I'm saying it back bring back just go on
Shark Tank and pigeon giant all right so
this is a 4-foot pie crust and it's
nothing it'll get through this unless
they use their teeth and it'll take a
while and there's no Jesus on this just
so don't get freaked out that we're
gonna go back to that sort of time I
mean look the way America is going we
might end up going back to standing
mince pies
oh but yeah just take note of these
things cuz here's the time when you and
I will probably be in some shed as I'm
loading a shotgun and you'll be like all
right you want a herring come on I
reached in the pie yeah just this is
what we can just take away from this is
that life was at one point just horrific
and was just a diarrhoea filled
nightmare yeah yeah I mean I think about
that all the time like what happened
when you got a headache or heartburn
when you had heartburn what toothache or
do you're just like I'm gonna kill
myself
that's over like I rarely get heartburn
oh dude but when I do you I take a
[ __ ] pill it goes away it goes away
you can I see months and all you can eat
is your [ __ ] three-month old pie
that's all you have and it's gonna keep
getting going back yeah you keep coming
back to the thing that's gonna light
your chest the place yeah well it sucks
gotta eat something I'm dying over here
though I think I've got a soffit you'll
hole so that's cool
good lord but I just keep going back to
all I can think about is there's no I
everybody didn't have constant diarrhea
it must have just been
horrible horrible just a horrific public
publicly just just a word like you're
heating it to three-month-old thing like
it's just yeah your body is like stop
there eating five-month old bird yeah
it's my guess is that you are gonna be
like oh something's not agreeing with me
do you think it's the half half a year
old bird I can't believe those two black
birds I ate that I killed last winter
and cooked or not making me feel good
alright well why do we round up the
family will go have some diarrhea in the
woods so it sound good to everybody make
a group trip
go do it I mean for everything where
people say we're not better off we're
yeah yeah well they have lax bathrooms I
think this one yeah that's true the lax
bathrooms are maybe something we're
getting close
yeah we're getting close to pretty much
a mince pie so getting closer well
they've did it normal I apologize yeah
man I'm sorry yes you should be thank
you thank you